the community in mourning in michigan
after three more american teenagers lost
their lives in a high school shooting it
all unfolded very quickly yesterday at
oxford high school an hour north of
detroit this makes no sense police
rushed in after reports of what turned
out to be a sophomore with a
semi-automatic pistol the shooter also
winded also wounded rather eight people
last night a vigil was held at a local
church with neighbors offering each
other support and lighting candles for
those who have been lost
this is at least the 28th school
shooting in america this year
nancy chen is in oxford michigan outside
the school nancy good morning to you
what can you tell us
gail good morning to you police say they
do have the suspect in custody but so
far the 15 year old is refusing to
cooperate investigators have searched
his home they also spent the night here
at the high school looking for clues but
a motive is still unclear
school shooting at oxford high school
the first 911 call was made at 12 51 pm
local time over 100 more calls followed
police officers were dispatched by 12 52
p.m and in the next two to three minutes
they had the suspect in custody a 15
year old sophomore armed with a
semi-automatic gun firing at least 12
rounds it was loaded at the time
and still contained seven rounds of
ammunition when they took it from him
that again i believe
interrupted what potentially could have
been seven more victims but before
police cleared sheltering students and
staff video from the school showed
students inside classrooms during those
terrifying minutes
in one video students can be seen
talking to someone on the other side of
a locked door who appears to want to
enter
sheriff
now we're not willing to take that risk
right now i can't hear you we're not
taking that risk right now okay well
come to the door look at my bag bro
yeah bro
he said bro
he said bro red flag
suspicious of the person on the other
side the students run out of the
classroom
to safety slow down you're fine
police do not yet know the shooter's
motive i have seen him around the school
and he's like he's a kid you know he's a
regular kid that goes to school
treyshawn bryant a senior said the
suspect had been bullied and he stayed
home from school after hearing threats
about a possible shooting the oakland
county sheriff's office says if there
were earlier warning signs they were
never notified three students were
killed tuesday including tate meer a 16
year old student athlete who died on the
way to the hospital we're not going to
see him in the hallways anymore we're
not going to see him in class we're not
going to like hear his laugh anymore
cassidy o'neill is a junior at oxford
high school she barricaded inside a
locked room with her boyfriend and
schoolmates
when we heard the shots it was just kind
of like i didn't understand that they
were like gunshots like this is
something you see in like movies like
this doesn't happen at oxford it doesn't
happen at my school
and the sheriff's office says the
suspect's father purchased the gun that
was used just last friday of the eight
surviving victims three are in critical
condition this morning local law
enforcement and the fbi are now sifting
through surveillance video and social
media for clues on what happened here
nate
our hearts goes out to those families we
need to work towards a day where we
don't have school shootings nancy thank
you so much